and there are a lot of people who are
for them and a lot of people are against
them it seems that most of the people
who are for them are essentially IP
holding companies who just sit around
and wait with patents and wait until
technology actually gets interesting
using something that could potentially
be covered by these patents and then
they sue people and they don't generally
they don't sue small companies they sue
Microsoft and IBM and of course IBM and
you know like all these big companies
have their own patents pools and they
use them as leverage against other
companies with patents but I just you
know I think there are so many problems
with it the biggest problems are that
you have people patenting things that
are essentially math which is what
patents are not supposed to be even
about at all and the I mean there are
other problems there no it's I'm usually
drunk when I give this explanation and
it comes out so much smoother I just
think that they're a big problem largely
because you can infringe on them without
knowing that you do and as a small
company you have like very you don't
have resources to go and research
whether or not you do that's I could
write a hundred thousand lines of code
and for all I know 50,000 of them
infringe on various things and I
wouldn't know that and normally if you
infringe someone's like trademark for
example if they don't enforce it it's to
your advantage because days they start
to lose their rights whereas patents if
they don't enforce it for ten years they
can come and sue you if for the ten
years that you've been making money on
their patent and you're completely
screwed so there's no incentive for them
to actually go and and tried it
legitimately license it it's it's really
the kind of thing where there are
probably there's place a middle ground
where it makes sense to have things be
patentable obviously in many places it
does make sense but things like software
and people patenting DNA it's it's it's
at the point where you have
things that are so abstract that they
really should belong to everybody and no
one's really like making viable
businesses on software patents the only
thing they're doing is extorting money
out of other people and the people who
have the most software patents probably
don't even want them to exist they're
just forced to do it
to cover their own asses